I today have for you a disgusting new
height of narcissism twelve hundred
dollar stimulus checks are potentially
being delayed because the narcissist and
chief Donald Trump wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks so it looks
like he's sending you the money people
are waiting for those $1,200 stimulus
payments some people have already gotten
them via direct deposit people who the
first batch was people who filed taxes
already electronically for tax dears
2018 or 2019 they were the first to
start getting $1,200 direct deposits
some people are now waiting on direct
deposits but then there's another group
and it's a group that's
disproportionately underbanked they may
either not have access to a bank account
they may or may not have regular access
to the internet to actually get set up
with direct deposit so they are waiting
for a paper check arguably those are the
people who most desperately need the
money and it's possible they are now
going to be delayed because as the
Washington Post reports the Treasury
Department has ordered the IRS to print
Donald Trump's name on the stimulus
checks a last-minute change which could
delay payments to millions and millions
of Americans now the Treasury is saying
well we're not sure that it's actually
going to cause a delay they're denying
that that's definitely the way that it's
going to go
it could cause checks to be delayed
several days or longer according to
senior Treasury officials so a couple
different things number one this has
never happened before never in history
has a president's name ever appeared on
an IRS disbursement now the Treasury
Department told the president you can't
be the one signing the checks Trump
wanted to be the one signing the checks
but Trump doesn't have signing authority
for funds coming from the Treasury or
IRS why because Trump is not formally
he's simply not on the list you know if
I have a business I have to tell the
bank who is allowed to sign checks for
my business Trump the president is not
allowed to sign checks from the Treasury
or IRS so what they're doing is instead
of Trump signing the checks it's so
pathetic how trig
this guy is by not having his name on
everything they're putting his name in
the memo because he can't sign the check
so instead his name is going in the memo
at first
Trump was insisting he has to sign them
he was told it's just not going to
happen so now this is what they're doing
if Trump is going to be signing anything
related to what's going on right now it
would make more sense for him to sign
the death certificates of people
tragically dying from coronavirus than
for him to be signing stimulus checks
because it's not his money it's really
our money and in reality he should be
signing nothing and we would all be
better off if he wasn't even involved in
the coronavirus response but that's
another story which you are probably
very familiar with at this point in time
Chad Hooper is the national president of
an organization for IRS managers Chad
Hooper says this is an abuse of
government resources
is anybody shocked by this though from
day one Trump has been abusing and
misusing government resources for his
own personal benefit it's not Trump's
money this has never been done before
Trump is used to putting his name on a
building and he wants it on the checks
and it is egomaniacal nonsense to the
nth degree and that doesn't change or
stop because we're in a pandemic this is
Donald Trump and the other factor of
this is this says a lot about what
Donald Trump thinks about the electorate
Donald Trump thinks the electorate is so
gullible and that voters are so shallow
that maybe they see Trump's name on the
check and they decide I'm going to go
and vote for him and I wish I was able
to tell you obviously that won't work
but Trump won in 2016 so clearly these
types of cheap bamboozling tactics these
cheap shallow tactics they do work on
many voters and that's the saddest thing
of all did you all cash your Trump
checks well then stop complaining about
him it's going to work on some voters
and it makes it all the more urgent that
we remove this malignancy in November
after the break I'm going to talk about
Barack Obama's endorsement of Joe Biden
I'm going to talk about Bernie Sanders
escalating his claims that
is irresponsible not to vote for Biden
in November that's Bernie who's saying
that all of that coming up after the
break make sure you're following me on
instagram at david pakman the urban
gardening coronavirus quarantine project
is growing by the day follow me on
instagram at david pakman to follow the
exciting adventure if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blinka stinketh lets you consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video